a powerful Facebook posts that spread
across the nation is starting a
conversation about the fear that many
black men have when walking alone in the
post
Shola Richards writes when I'm walking
down the street holding my young
daughter's hand and walking my sweet
fluffy dog I'm just a loving dad and a
pet owner but without them by my side
almost instantly I morph into a threat
in the eyes of some white folks it's
equal parts exhausting and depressing to
feel like I can't walk around outside
alone for fear of being targeted and
surely Richard Richards joins us now
from Los Angeles Shola
good morning it's such a powerful post
and it reminds me of the idea that white
people often say we're colorblind but
that is its own kind of privilege it's
easy to become a blind when your race is
not making you very self-conscious how
often in your day-to-day life are you
made aware the color of your skin good
morning and thanks for having me all the
time there's not a day that passes where
I wake up and I'm not aware of Who I am
skin color I have how that presents
certain challenges and it's you know not
meant to be in a place of victimization
it's just the reality of what I face on
a daily basis that I have to experience
and now having to teach to my daughters
yeah I think there are some people who
might hear the walk around the block
story and think oh I'll use being
sensitive
but there's the Amazon Prime story that
I think really brings this idea home
imagine a neighbor asks you to pick up
their packages off of their porch how
would you feel about that scenario it's
funny because yes thank you for sharing
that that's a real story one of my very
good friends the neighbor of mine had a
bunch of Amazon packages are piled up on
his front porch he was on vacation he's
like hey Shola can you run across the
street and grab my packages and bring
them back to my house and I'll pick them
up once I get home the idea of me going
to a house that's not mine picking up
packages that don't belong to me and
then carrying them down the street or
loading them into my car I think it's
well I would hope it's obvious to some
people how they could play out poorly
for me
so it's these things that seemingly are
innocuous to most people but to me could
be potentially coming a bad situation or
bad position are things I have to think
about before I act every single day yeah
I know it's easy to imagine a neighbor
well-intentioned as they may be having a
preconception about who is going to
steal packages and call the police
because they see you in particular
what's also striking about your post is
you address some of the common responses
to black lives matter and to our
national confrontation right now with
racism one of them is all lives matter
your response to that I mean I just I
really struggle with this concept of all
lives matter they I know on the surface
it may seem like it's a good response
but in reality it's not the analogy I
often use is that if I went to the
doctor and I broke my arm and the
doctors response to me was to my pain
it's like hey Shola all bones matter I'm
like yeah man I understand that that's
clear but right now my arm is broken and
there's only one bone in crisis right
now it's my arm so for you to bring up
other bones or all bones seem to be just
silly
I'm not gonna run into a lymphoma
society meeting and start screaming
breast cancer matters like all cancer
matters like let's focus on the issue
and let's really focus on the area that
needs the most help
yeah let's focus so as we're in this
moment of focus what do you hope people
take away from your story and all the
stories being shared right now well
first of all I'm so grateful this I'm an
optimist but this feels different this
feels like the energy that we're seeing
from good white men and women and all
colors black brown coming together in
these marches my hope is that we
continue this that we do more than just
putting the blackout square on your
profile photo on social media and
continue activism continue to be an ally
make mistakes screw up get embarrassed
try again course
but whatever you do just don't stop
because we're in a place now where we
can't be distracted by basketball game
the football games Kovach nineteen's
cancelled everything so let's use this
time to learn to read to have meaningful
conversations and most importantly to
keep showing up every single day to
fight this yeah focus focus in action
all right shoulder Richards and Richards
thank you very much